I want to assemble a task force of the
most dangerous people on the planet
they're bad guys worst of the worst
[Music]
was this cheerleading trials to do
something that would get you killed
save the world I can't wait to show you
my toys
you
seriously the hell's wrong with you
people for bad guys that's what we do
Zeus a dog squirt
hey youtubers is Charlie they slipped in
some new Suicide Squad this past weekend
with some slightly different footage
this is just an international version of
the trailer so let's break it down the
difference of this footage is it's
mostly just highlighting the powers of
all the different Suicide Squad members
Killer Croc Captain Boomerang the Joker
you even have some more Batman footage
in Ben Affleck's Batman will have a
cameo in this they actually did confirm
that the events of Suicide Squad pick up
after the events of Batman V Superman so
just careful for spoilers from Batman V
Superman I'll talk a little bit about
what happens at the end of that movie as
grim and dark is the way they ended that
movie was I feel like Suicide Squad is
much more in that tone so if you really
like the tone of Batman V Superman I
feel like you're really gonna like
Suicide Squad because it just it lends
itself to that kind of storytelling and
it seems like based on what Ben Affleck
has said Batman his Batman character is
inspired by Wonder Woman and Superman's
actions so he renews his quest to take
down villains which starts with the
Joker now I did talk about it a little
bit during my Batman V Superman Easter
egg videos because of the Robin suit
because this is post death in the family
he's already killed Robin we don't know
how long ago that happened but
presumably sometime in the last 20 years
Wayne Manor he gets burnt down at the
end of that comic book storyline so that
might have also happened to Wayne Manor
in this story it remains to be seen
Batman kind of looks like he hasn't
tried to repair Wayne Manor so it might
not be fire might just be neglect and I
think the really exciting opportunity
for Suicide Squad on you know on top of
like all these really awesome characters
in the idea of metahumans is the idea of
magic in the DC Universe Wonder Woman
flows a lot from Greek mythology which
is close to magic it's not quite the
same thing but you have characters like
enchantress like they say in the trailer
you're possessed by a witch I just I
cannot wait for this movie to get super
weird and super awesome I feel like you
expect characters like Batman and
Superman to be a little more
straightforward you can get way weirder
with Suicide Squad characters which is
why I feel like the tone of the Zack
Snyder universe lends itself more to
Suicide Squad type stories so a lot of
the complaints I feel like people have
made against Batman V Superman I feel
like will work in the favor of Suicide
Squad so definitely get hype I feel like
the same thing is gonna happen with the
new Batman films and we actually just
learned this really interesting thing
Ben Affleck has already written the
new Batman film it's supposed to be a
trilogy but he's only written one so far
and he's only under contract through
Justice League part two so a lot of
people are speculating that he's just
kind of waiting to see how all these
movies work out before he signs on for
more movies it's not like a Marvel
situation where he's under contract for
six movies so yes there's supposed to be
three more Batman films but it looks
like right now they only have a really
strong idea for one film which I'm
totally fine with you really don't want
to plan too far ahead but it is good to
know what they're thinking about behind
the scenes like okay we're thinking
through Justice League we're thinking
new Batman trilogy if everything works
out the way we wanted to obviously
there's gonna be Suicide Squad sequels
well let me know in the comments do you
feel like the tone of the DC Universe
will work more in Suicide Squad favors
than it will unlike Batman in supermans
favor I just feel like if it's gonna be
really dark really cynical and gritty it
is gonna be a lot more fun to watch
characters that also flow from that same
energy that's actually a pretty
interesting idea a movie universe that
is friendlier to its villains than it is
to its heroes so in related news of you
guys didn't know Captain America Civil
War stuff is ramping up that movie is
happening in May I know a lot of you
have asked me to do more x-men videos
that movie is coming soon to I'll start
to do more x-men stuff as we get closer
to that film this is really gonna be one
of those big years for comic book movies
I'm really excited about
there is no comic book movie that I'm
not crazy hype about there is a new
episode of arrow tonight I'll post a
video out after it airs they also
released a trailer for Jonah Hex on
legends of tomorrow so if I don't get to
that I will totally talk about Jonah Hex
in my next Legends video I think the
real challenge for me this year is just
gonna be keeping up with all the really
awesome stuff which is like the best
problem to have so while you guys wait
for my arrow video to post tonight you
can click here for the Captain America
civil war trailer I just posted and you
can click here for all my Batman V
Superman Easter eggs thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight